good morning the BBC's Flagship football
show match of the day will air tonight
but with no presenters no regular
commentators and no pundits that is as
the Fallout from the corporation's
decision to take Gary lineker off air
intensifies and breaking news as well to
bring you in the last few minutes Sky
News understands that the BBC's Football
Focus program will not at all today that
is with the presenter and pundits
withdrawing from that program well
lineker was forced off match of the day
in a row over impartiality as after he
compared the language used to launch a
new government migrant policy with 1930s
Germany fellow regulars on the show Ian
Wright and Alan Shearer then said that
they would not be taking part in
solidarity with lineker and then several
of the show's commentators released this
joint statement last night it reads we
have decided to step down from Saturday
night's broadcast we are comforted that
football fans who want to watch their
teams should still be able to do so as
management can use World feed commentary
if they wish however in the
circumstances we do not feel it would be
appropriate to take part in the program
and in the last half an hour the
professional footballers Association has
released this statement which reads we
have been informed that players involved
in today's games will not be asked to
participate in interviews with match of
the day the PFA have been speaking to
members who wanted to take a collective
position and to be able to show their
support for those who have chosen not to
be part of tonight's program during
those conversations we made clear that
as their Union we would support all
members who might face consequences for
choosing not to complete their broadcast
commitments this is a common sense
decision that ensures that players won't
now be put in that position
well Skye's Rachel venables joins me now
she's outside new Broadcasting House in
central London and political political
correspondent Rob Powell is waiting to
speak to us as well in Westminster
um morning Rachel to you first the
ripples of this are going out far and
wide aren't they is is the BBC losing
control over the situation
thank you
the communications to Rachel venables
there let's see if we can go to our
studio in Westminster and and bring in
our political correspondent Rob Powell
um Rob of course all of this The Wider
picture is the power structures that
govern the UK
um it's looking tricky isn't it the BBC
trying to extricate itself from
political partiality uh accusations yeah
sort of the age-old tensions if you like
that are present within the BBC's
position as an independent organization
but also an independent organization
that relies on a charter agreed with the
government of the day for its very
existence at the moment the message
coming from the government is that this
is essentially nothing to do with them
this is a ride between Gary lineker and
the BBC and it should stay as thus but
of course the last few days have seen
cabinet ministers the Home Secretary
swella bravaman being very critical
about Gary Indiana his comments about
their approach to tackling cross-channel
migration we've seen Tory backbenchers
even more vocal 30 or so MPS and peers
wrote to the director General overnight
calling for an investigation into Gary
lineker labor as well are essentially
accusing the corporation accusing the
BBC of pandering to the government and
pandering to parts of the press in
taking Gary lineker off air I think the
reality is slightly more nuanced than
what labor make out though because the
context of this within the BBC anyway is
an ongoing drive by the current director
General Tim Davey on impartiality now in
part that is is being driven is set
against a backdrop of increasing
political pressure and concern on the
BBC over impartiality clearly under
Boris Johnson there were the most acute
and vocal questions being asked about
BBC impartiality but even more recent to
moderate secretaries have said that the
BBC has a way to go on the issue Tim
David set out things like a 10-point
plan A couple of years ago to look into
social media use by BBC staff and
employees we have also seen over that
period
um big Name BBC stars like Emily matless
and Andrew Marr leave in part because
they say they want to be able to
essentially find more of a voice and put
more of their views out without the
restrictions the BBC places on them but
I think what we see in this Gary lineker
row is the sort of most high profile
Clash or the most high-profile failure
to square this circle when this drive on
impartiality collides with really the
reality of how big modern media
personalities use social media to get
involved in big public debates the BBC
needs to square this circle and find
some way forward to sort of resolve some
of these contradictions because the end
situation you end up in is one where of
of course you have high profile football
programs being taken off air or being
aired without any presenters or pundits
on and ultimately the body that loses
out the most from all of that is the BBC